does Kelsey like read you a book we've
been reading she doesn't read me a book
oh sorry I don't know what you guys do
actually we have this one couple friend
that reads together like they read out
loud to each other at night did popcorn
yeah they do I thought it was the
weirdest [__] when I heard it and
they're like no it's nice because we
read the same book and it's like quality
time that we spend together I'd be like
so pissed like you're reading too slow I
know I couldn't I could be the reader
but I couldn't sit there and list like
be read to yeah following along in your
own book you guys are [__] weird that
is weird
what's up
their life [__] changes in their in
your 30s I'm telling you it's like you
like start to like weird [__] like that
popcorn reading with your partner yes
because it's like you guys in bunk beds
well no we're not siblings
siblings a bunk bed that would be sad
that would be really sad hey babe you
comfy down now
good night
I'll try not to
[Laughter]
what I need to go pee pee
babe I need to get down yeah so
but I read do you read
oh yeah yeah okay I want to talk about
the court of thorns or whatever do you
really now because now I've when we
first talked about it I don't didn't
really like absorb what you're talking
about sure and then
you're visiting some friends on the
weekend and we were talking about books
because again that's a big 30s that's
what you do so what are you guys reading
each other these days
literally it's like we went to visit
this couple that has this one-year-old
child and it's just the most like
I don't know it's just the most like 30
[__] of all time you know you like
talking to them and they're like every
third word they're like hold on go and
grab the child as he's like trying to
get you know her injured or something
like that you're annoyed you're like can
you like put her somewhere no we're like
love we love it you know okay we want to
be around the baby it's like I don't
know that's what I'm saying weirdo
anyways yeah you want to be around
babies freaking weirdo
because I want one you know sure okay I
wanna want to have one right right right
okay yeah just take theirs
we're thinking about it
so we're like sitting there and we're
like what are you reading and she was
like well I'm reading this like it's
this I don't wanna you know it's like
it's like fantasy
but it's like porn yeah it's like it's
like a romance book at the same time it
was like Port of thorns and Roses yes it
was that so she was telling me about it
and it sounded uh intense but it sounds
pretty hot honestly look we could do
some popcorn reading of a court of
thorns and Roses it's very like it gets
well that's the fun part though is like
It's A Beautiful World building book
where it's kind of like Game of Thrones
where you just get lost in it you know
and it's like oh yeah that's how it
works in this world yeah yeah and it's
like that but the characters are very
lovable and it's obviously kind of like
it's good I really and it's what does
that mean like did these fairies they
actually [__]
do they pardon how like explicit does it
get because like when everyone's
whenever someone's like yeah it's like a
romance novel and then you do the face
yeah you're like so how explicit is the
sex because I know like in in in you
know written porn it's like you know she
Strokes his like veiny member does it is
it like that like yeah really well not
like gross like that it's obviously
written very beautifully and
romantically oh yeah fairy member veiny
glittery
yeah no it's it's it's a good mixture of
like it's always romantic but yeah it
gets pretty graphic all right pulled up
the full [__] transcript of it you
really did it's it's tea because the
first book you start out really loving a
character and by the end of the series
it's like I can't wait for him to die oh
really yeah it's great and do they die
I won't reveal oh okay you're gonna have
to read it yeah but apparently it's like
she's like yeah the first one was good
it was like 500 pages yeah and then the
second one's like 650 and the third
one's like 790 or something but it's
like
right just got excited she's got a
little snot bubble I love it I love this
book
um yeah it's like I was trying to carry
it around in my backpack and it was like
a [__]
dictionary with me I think I would
honestly the girls would love if you
would read Court of thorns and Roses
well I read uh Daisy Jones in the six
did you really yeah I read it too I just
finished it it's [__] great
and the show's coming out I know yep
that's the best thing about it
the fact that you read that well Kelsey
likes her books yeah and uh she read uh
Evelyn Hugo first I'm reading that right
now yeah that that's a great one well
I'm I've been told that Daisy Jones I
love that we're talking about this by
the way Daisy Jones and the six I've
been told was better than the Evelyn
Hugo one and so I was like okay I'll
start there and then like I finished it
right on time because they just had a
premiere for it okay and I was like how
do I sneak in how do I sneak in yeah I
want to see the first episode but uh
yeah that author is really great she's
really good at um
kind of like creating a lack for lack of
a better term A vibe sure like but for
whatever like Niche she's talking about
like whether it's Hollywood or like
grunge rock or tennis or whatever she
knows how to like use the right
terminology and like build this world
where you really feel like you're there
like you know the with Daisy Jones and
the six are all like doing heroin and
[__] up all the time yeah and the way
he describes like the way Daisy's acting
you're like oh yeah she's a total addict
and yeah but like it's like romantic in
a way you know classic addict yeah
because classic addicts be like yeah
she's doing heroin again oh man okay me
when I yeah
yeah it's very um
I agree because the whole vibe of Daisy
Jones and the six is it's a rock and
roll documentary you know oral history
whatever and uh it makes you think of
every rock and roll documentary you've
ever watched that's what I'm saying I've
got the exact same energy yeah as an a
real band yeah and a real documentary
about that band I was getting pissed
towards the ends they were talking about
like songs they were writing this and I
was like looking up on YouTube I'm like
where is there like a video with lyrics
well they did they wrote they wrote
songs for the show yeah you can't
[__] wait I listened to one of them
it's too bad don't tell me that was bad
no no it's not bad it's just
I guess I pictured it to be better like
I'm picturing like Fleetwood Mac level
music you know well that's what it's
based on yeah that's what I'm saying so
I'm I I picked is it really yeah it's
based on so there's and she's Stevie
Nicks yeah there's this famous
um performance of Silver Springs by
Fleetwood Mac from 1994. and um it's
Stevie singing to Lindsay and uh it's
the lyric that's like you'll never get
away from the sound of a woman that
loves you and that whole performance is
so [__] iconic because they had all
been fighting and [__] Fleetwood
Mac's [__] crazy drama and that
moment this is rumors that I've heard
the whole book is based on that because
it's like
everyone what an interesting concept
like one of the most famous bands in the
world and everyone's [__] and
fighting obsessed yeah of course right
about yeah yeah
it's the best have you ever [__]
anybody in your band or on tour right
just Ryan oh yep wow that's a
complicated history makes things very
awkward I bet look I bet you guys we're
both married
yeah okay very good I felt that energy
when I walked in the room yeah you're
like you can cut this sexual attention
with a knife yeah damn yeah just kiss
Owen
would like that my phone's going off
I'ma just kiss already
I'm really excited so I like to read
like boring like Finance or Tech books
half the time that are non-fiction
that's my favorite yeah but then I
intersperse it with like a really good
just like fiction read that you just
don't want to put down and uh those are
the ones so Kelsey last year read Evelyn
Hugo and then she read Daisy Jones last
December and she's like you've got to
read it and I was like
that book's for girls babe
I'm not reading that okay cool book
about a hedge fund to read all right and
then literally a year later
I'm like let's see what [__] Daisy
Johnson is all about yeah yeah yeah it
was great I loved it oh that is so good
to hear yeah Embrace men Embrace reading
girl books but why is it a girl book I
know like Fleetwood Mac is only for
girls it's not at all the opposite I
would argue so yeah that's what I was
gonna say is I was expecting music like
that because their music [__] like
touches you yeah
and so I'm picturing that type of music
and especially with the way they
described that album and how people
responded to it and the fact that they
went to playing stadiums I'm like oh
these songs must be unbelievable and
then to like bring them to life and not
do it justice really was kind of like I
mean it's fine but it's not like
anything special sure well they had
someone do the
the music for it it was like a producer
yeah here it is Daisy Jones and the six
regret me
oh my God it's so it's real they made it
yeah
it's for the show
I don't know if I hold it away like this
it's not gonna get we'll play it in the
bonus yeah but if I hold it away like
this you won't hear it through the mic
it looks so
the album it's not important here it is
Lake Mills how do you see okay POV
you're sitting down reading a [__]
Tech book yeah are you taking notes no
are you like
what are you doing man
he's like camped in a Starbucks like
he's doing my research
Little Light reading no it's just
entertaining as [__] this is the one
that I'm reading right now but I've
described this before so I'm not gonna
keep going but like
like I would I used to be a software
engineer so this [__] just like
interests me I love this world and
finance especially for some reason I
don't know why I never studied it I
never like
but for the the world of like trading
and hedge funds and
and financial crimes especially a holler
crime is that's crazy
seriously yeah I love it